around latajang china's government has
ordered a lockdown on gar county in her
nan province it borders who Bay which
was the epicenter of the corona virus
outbreak in China 600,000 people have
been ordered not to leave their homes
unless they have official permission the
order came after an infected man came
into contact with two doctors who then
tested positive the new lockdown has
sparked fears of a second wave of
infection just as China is restarting
the walls second biggest economy
after months of enforced quarantine
China's foreign ministry says US
officials are shameless for accusing
Beijing of covering up the true picture
of the outbreak a Ministry spokeswoman
accused the Americans of politicizing a
health issue what was the short war we
have said multiple times that slanders
smears and finger-pointing cannot make
up for the last time they'll only cause
more lost time and lives if they
continue to lie just like China did at
the start of the epidemic many countries
in the region have imposed tough
restrictions on movement Malaysia is
reporting early signs of a slowdown in
the infection rate but the government
says strict control measures need to be
adhered to the president of the
Philippines has ordered soldiers and
police to shoot anyone who violates the
mandatory month-long
lockdown Rodrigo Duterte issued the
warning after protests by residents in a
poor area of Manila complaining about
the lack of food and government aid but
the merengue my orders are to the police
and military also with the village
officials if there are troubles or
occasions where there's violence and
your lives are in danger
dead rights groups have criticized his
remarks with Amnesty International
calling them heartless and unjustifiable
Florence lui al Jazeera